difficile at il dit le nouveau
gouvernement devrait être connu mercredi
après nous avant le conseil des
ministres des anciens ministres français
visés par la justice la cour de justice
de la république va ouvrir une enquête
sur la gestion de la crise sanitaire
contre edouard philippe olivier ferrand
et agnès buzyn alors que le parlement a
adopté la nuit dernière le projet de loi
de sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
les indicateurs ne montre pas de reprise
de l'épidémie en france mais on fera le
point également sur l'épidémie aux états
unis notait la chine de nouveau sous le
feu des critiques américaines washington
dénonce les exercices militaires de
pékin en mer de chine méridionale
les etats unis qui adopte également des
sanctions contre des responsables
chinois qui appliquent les nouvelles
règles sécuritaires répressive contre
hong kong
une loi adoptée hier par le congrès pour
accroître la pression sur pékin
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce soir l'émotion
d'edouard philippe qui a passé le
pouvoir à jean castex dans la cour de
matignon en fin d'après-midi un passage
de relais amical entre les deux hommes
qui se connaissent puisqu'ils ont
travaillé notamment sur le plan de
déconfinement de la france ensemble
chacun a loué les qualités respectives
et edouard philippe qui a été longuement
applaudi la remercie emmanuel macron
avec qui il a travaillé pendant trois
ans et il a souhaité du succès à son
successeur les premiers mots de jean
castex lui en tant que premier ministre
ont été pour souligner le contexte
particulièrement difficile actuel et à
venir les précisions sur place de notre
reporter kirill kotick
c'est avec presque des sanglots dans la
voix qui edouard philippe a effectué son
discours d'adieu dans la cour de l'hôtel
matignon un discours marqué par des
remerciements chaleureux envers son
équipe qui l'a accompagné durant ces
trois ans en poste servait la france
soyez bon vous avez la carrure pour
mener la barque
c'est avec ces mots que le désormais ex
premier ministre a accueilli son
successeur il est vrai que les deux
hommes se connaissent ils ont travaillé
ensemble lors de la gestion difficile de
cette crise sanitaire jean castex a
salué le travail d'edouard philippe
rappelant son dévouement et son style un
style edouard philippe il est vrai qu
edouard philippe s'est démarqué à
plusieurs reprises par son humour lors
de son mandat il a ensuite fait savoir
que de nombreux défis restaient à être
relevés que de nouvelles méthodes
devrait être appliquée non seulement
face à cette crise sanitaire qui est
toujours là mais aussi face à celle
économique et social qui perdure je vous
souhaite très sincèrement beaucoup de
réussite
beaucoup de succès du succès pour vous
bien entendu mais surtout du succès pour
notre pays qui sort n'est pas encore
complètement sortis d'une crise
sanitaire dont vous savez tous les
aspects tous les dangers mais aussi
toutes les mesures qui ont été prises
pour lutter contre ces effets et notre
pays qui a traversé cette crise
sanitaire qui a traversé d'autres crises
a besoin d'un esprit ouvert et d'une
main ferme
mais je pense que vous avez cet esprit
ouvert et cette main ferme
la crise économique et sociale elle est
déjà là
les priorités devront donc évoluer les
méthodes devront donc être adaptées et
il nous faudra plus que jamais réunir la
nation pour lutter contre cette crise
qui s'installe et surtout dans la
continuité des réformes de fond que vous
avez entrepris pour faire en sorte que
nous en sortions plus fort et plus
solidaire edouard philippe a été
fortement applaudie par l'auditoire dans
la cour de l'hôtel matignon qu'il quitte
désormais définitivement pour retourner
dans son fief du havre ce sera désormais
au tour de jean castex de former un
nouveau gouvernement
nouveau gouvernement qui devrait être
présenté à emmanuel macron d'ici
quelques jours
ancien directeur de cabinet de xavier
bertrand et ancien secrétaire général de
l'elysée sous nicolas sarkozy jean
castex n'est pas très connu du grand
public
c'est un homme de droite élu local et
fin connaisseur de l'administration
française
portrait de cet énarque gascon de 55 ans
et père de quatre enfants théo comble
longtemps homme de l'ombre
jean castex vient brutalement d'entrer
dans la lumière né dans le gers
diplômé de sciences po et de l'ena tout
comme edouard philippe
celui qui aime se considérer comme un
serviteur de l'état a fait l'intégralité
de sa carrière dans l'administration
ce proche de xavier bertrand effectué
ces armes à partir de 2006 auprès de
l'actuel président de la région des
hauts de france il devient son directeur
de cabinet au ministère de la santé et
le suit au ministère du travail
maire du petit village de prades dans
les pyrénées orientales depuis 2008 il
occupe les fonctions de conseiller aux
affaires sociales auprès de la
présidence en 2010 au crépuscule du
mandat de nicolas sarkozy
il devient secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée
réputé droit et travailleurs ceux qui le
connaissent sont dithyrambiques
c'est tout sauf un courtisan c'est un
mélange assez inédit de très grande
connaissance de l'appareil de l'état et
de sensibilité du terrain grâce à son
mandat de maire de prades
cela lui donne une forme de bon sens de
recul par rapport aux jeux de pouvoir
malgré son échec aux législatives de
2012 sous l'étiquette ump jean castex ne
manque pas de sollicitations
il entre dans l'équipe de campagne de
françois fillon lorsque ce dernier
brigue la présidence du parti en 2012
une aventure qui te poursuivra lorsque
l'ancien premier ministre se lance dans
la bataille de la présidentielle de 2017
mais c'est en 2020 que cette éminence
grise apparaît sur le devant de la scène
lorsqu'il devient le monsieur
déconfinement du gouvernement il faut
que notre nation que notre pays retrouve
les voix de la vie tout court de la vie
économique sinon on voit bien qu un
confinement trop prolongée pourrait
avoir des conséquences
vous l'avez d'ailleurs dit aussi
désastreuse que la pandémie membre de
longue date des républicains le parti
dirigé par christian jacob doit faire
face à une nouvelle défection
une belle prise de guerre pour emmanuel
macron qu'ils soient définitivement
tourné la page du très populaire edouard
philippe
une nomination qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité dans la classe politique qui
agace on l'a vu quelque peu à droite
puisque ce nouveau ce nouvel élu les
républicains a rallié lui aussi la
majorité présidentielle écoutez je
connais et j'apprécie les qualités
deux serviteurs de l'état de jean castex
elles seront indispensables dans les
moments difficiles que nous allons
connaître
puisse-t-elle corriger les mauvais choix
du président de la république des
missions gouvernement premier ministre
et donc castex est chargé du
déconfinement à droite d'emmanuel macron
tout cela fleure bon la cuisine
électorale présidentielle pour préparer
vous connaissez jean castex monsieur
déconfinement nommé à la place d'edouard
philippe en voilà un qui ne risque pas
de faire de l'ombre à macron par sa
popularité le roi macron règnera enfin
seuls restent à se débarrasser du
parlement jean castex premier ministre
voilà le grand choc démocratique tant
attendu et l'époustouflante réinvention
du président de la république jean
castex le multi casquettes cumulards ex
délégué aux jeux olympiques
ex secrétaire général de sarkozy nommé
premier ministre de l'ex banquier ex
secrétaire général de hollande la vème
république des lobbys continue et voyez
à présent ce qu'en pensent les français
nous sommes allés dans les rues de paris
leur demander leur avis écoutez je
connaissais l'ancien mais le nouveau
jean castex aucune idée je sais pas d'où
il vient j'ai jamais entendu ce nom
quelque part je ne connais pas du tout
et comme mon collègue je connaissais pas
le son prédécesseur du coup je suppose
qu'il retourne à la mairie chez lui là
vers vers le havre c'est ça c'est
formidable qui espère qu'il va faire du
bon boulot alors
ouais je sais ce que c'est
on espère prise d'air du bon boulot mais
est ce que vous voyez qui a pas du tout
je connais pas du tout c'est monsieur et
je l' ai vu un petit peu j'ai vu que
visiblement ça a été un grand acteur
pour la france dans le commandement dans
le gué confinement à l'heure actuelle
nous faut vraiment du concret quoi ses
pions doit avoir quelqu'un qui on doit
avoir quelqu'un qui fait les choses et
qui prend des sachant qu'un premier
ministre pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui
est en dessous du président mais qui a
quand même une certaine importance et
qui doit être en mesure de prendre des
décisions bon qu'il soit connu de tout
le monde joue pas il suffit tout soit
compétent donc tu sois compétents et
surtout c'est la compétence qui compte
après tout et voyez à présent les
réactions de nos invités sur ce plateau
concernant la nomination de jean castex
et le départ d'edouard philippe de son
poste de premier ministre
jean castex et quelqu'un d'honorable de
respectables qui connaît parfaitement
les rouages de l'état et donc je pense
qu'il est capable d'effectuer demande
aux jurés matignon mais là n'est pas la
question d'accord moi je voudrais dire
que edouard philippe
pendant trois ans a conduit des réformes
sérieuses importante à réduire déficits
et a su affronter une crise absolument
inédite qui est celle de claudine ticket
du coc vide où il a même montré je
trouve plus de solidité que le président
bon et il a décidé de quitter matignon
je conçois en réalité le virage que le
président de la république de prendre
est un virage ce qui ne lui convenait
pas plus de dépenses pour préparer des
élections présidentielles 2022 est
plutôt que de s'accrocher à un poste au
détriment de ses convictions il a choisi
de partir se trouve ça très très
honorable et respectable
je pense que c'est surtout la
confirmation que dans la vème république
le président la république ne supporte
pas que le produit fini soit plus
populaire que lui ou est ce qu'il ya un
tournant je veux dire jean castex avec
tous les mérites qui sont les siens ses
grandes compétences de hauts
fonctionnaires d'élu local maire de
prades
mais il n'a pas des convictions
l'orientation politique d'aidé des
prises de position
tellement différente de celle d'edouard
philippe il n'y a donc pas de changement
de cap à la tête du gouvernement
n'arrange je pense qu'effectivement pour
des raisons diverses et sur des sujets
compliqués
le président la république ne souhaite
pas qu'il y ait commandé 26 ans voire
des contradictions entre l'elysée et
matignon
non mais les nerfs sont devenus la nex
de la macro ni c'est une annexe
tellement visible que madame macro
maintenant ce cher et se sert de du
parti des républicains pour piocher ses
premiers ministres il l'a fait avec
eller chez lipp il le fait avec jean
castex donc les verts n'ont pas avoir de
candidat présidentiel leur candidat
c'est emmanuel macron il n'y a pas
d'autre chose
les républicains n'existe plus leur
leader leurs idées sont au pouvoir à
travers edouard philippe est aujourd'hui
jean castex et avec on sait très bien
que la vraie guerre va commencer à la
rentrée
c'est une guerre qui sera mené contre
les travailleurs contre les classes
populaires on sait très bien ce qu'il
veut faire
on n'est absolument pas dupes de ce
remaniement que juste de la
communication et de la vieille politique
dont franchement on n'a pas vraiment
besoin
surtout quand on a un taux d'abstention
aussi élevé je crois que les français
attendent autre chose et voilà pour les
réactions politiques
edouard philippe qui sera élu maire du
havre un dimanche mais qui ne quitte pas
tout à fait paris vous allez le voir il
se serait vu confier à la mission de
rassembler les sensibilités politiques
compatibles avec la république en marche
en vue de la présidentielle de 2000 22
aujourd'hui en tout cas l'ancien chef du
gouvernement quitte ses fonctions en
étant plus populaire que jamais
retour sur ces trois années passées à
matignon avec clément hospital très
sincèrement
c'est un nouveau souffle pour le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron le revers
subi par la république en marche aux
élections municipales a convaincu le
président de la nécessité de remanier
son gouvernement
ils se séparent donc de son premier
ministre à deux ans de la fin de son
mandat l'occasion d'un nouveau départ
pour edouard philippe qui a multiplié
les déplacements ces dernières semaines
entre l'elysée la cité normande
le locataire de matignon avait laissé
entrevoir la possibilité d'un éventuel
départ du gouvernement pour reprendre sa
casquette de maire mon objectif c'est
d'être maire du havre vite ça peut
arriver très vite si ça arrive très vite
ça sera très bien
l'épidémie de coronavirus a poussé
emmanuel macron à ouvrir le troisième
acte de son quinquennat la crise
sanitaire a fragilisé la majorité
déstabilisé par les tensions sociales
permanente et avec l'arrivée de la crise
économique le président a dû poser un
acte fort en se séparant de son homme
providentiel pour reprendre la main au
cours de ces trois dernières années
edouard philippe a maintes fois servi de
bouclier à emmanuel macron notamment
face aux mouvements des gilet jaune
le premier ministre avait alors défendu
la réponse ferme de l'exécutif face aux
débordements lors des manifestations à
paris
on va utiliser tous les moyens de droit
et toutes les mobilités tout le
dynamisme dont nous pouvons faire preuve
pour répondre à ceux qui viennent mettre
en cause les forces de l'ordre
mettre en cause la propriété privée vous
m'entendez bien nous allons mettre en
voit tous les moyens de droit et tous
les moyens dans la mobilisation dans la
stratégie des forces de l'ordre pour
faire en sorte que nous puissions
apporter une réponse qui ne rendent plus
possible ses actes un recours à la force
présent également dans le processus
législatif le premier ministre avait
engagé la responsabilité du gouvernement
sur la réforme controversée des
retraites
l'article 49 alinéa 3 a permis
l'adoption du projet en première lecture
avant les élections municipales
mais la crise sanitaire a ensuite amené
emmanuel macron à geler toutes les
réformes conformément à l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la constitution de 1958 et
après en avoir obtenu l'autorisation du
conseil des ministres du 29 février
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite non pour mettre fin au débat
mais pour mettre fin à cet épisode de
non débat à un parlement privé de sa
fonction éminente de faire la loi
alors que c'est la fin du règne des
doigts félipe à la tête du pouvoir
gouvernemental
la cote de confiance du maire du havre
poursuit sa progression avec 51%
d'opinions favorables soit un gain de 13
points depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire durant laquelle il a été très
exposé et alors qu edouard philippe
quitte matignon on apprend qu'une
enquête judiciaire sera ouverte contre
le premier ministre pour sa gestion de
la crise sanitaire
trois ministres sont visés ollier
olivier ferrand à la santé agnès buzyn
ce après des six trice enquête ouverte
par la cour à la cour de justice de la
république annoncé ce vendredi par le
procureur général près de la cour de
cassation françois molins la commission
des requêtes qui est composée de hauts
magistrats et qui fait office de filtre
a en effet jugé recevable neuf plaintes
contre ses anciens membres du
gouvernement et dans ce contexte de
remaniement le ségur de la santé a été
prolongée faute d'accord le paquet de
mesures promis par le gouvernement 1 n'a
pas été présenté ce vendredi ils
devraient l'être la semaine prochaine
olivier ferrand a promis hier une
enveloppe de 400 millions d'euros
supplémentaires au personnel hospitalier
une rallonge qui porte à 6,4 milliards
le montant des mesures salariales mais
c'est insuffisant pour le secrétaire
général de la branche santé de force
ouvrière il demande près de 10 milliards
d'euros pour le public et pour le privé
et on en vient tout de suite à la
pandémie du coran navire
la pandémie du coronavirus avec le
nombre de nouvelles infections
quotidienne qui dépasse la barre des 160
mille nouveaux cas dans le monde
c'est ce sont des chiffres donnés par
l'instance onusienne au brésil un
millier de morts supplémentaires en 24
heures selon le ministre de la santé au
total soixante mille décès liés aux
convives dans ce pays vous allez voir
les bars et les restaurants ont rouvert
à rio de janeiro après trois mois de
fermeture envoyer les réactions sur
place
nous faisons tout ce que l' agence
publique à déterminer la science
détermine donc l' isolement la
distanciation social le gel
hydroalcoolique les toilettes tout ce
que nous faisons déjà
maintenant c'est aussi aux clients de
respecter la distanciation social stable
c'était effrayant parce qu'il y a une
grosse chute dans les ventes ça nous a
permis de voir certaines failles que
nous avions certaines économies que nous
aurions pu faire fut nous avons
découvert d'autres façons de travailler
pour moi il devrait attendre un peu
avant de rouvrir
rien n'a été résolu le virus n'a pas
disparu c'est toujours là et avec cette
réouverture
les gens commencent à voir la fausse
impression que tout est rentré dans
l'ordre
donc ils vont devenir fou et aux
etats-unis +2 à 53 mille infections
enregistrées ces dernières 24 heures
selon l'université john hopkins
les américains qui se prépare à la fête
nationale du 4 juillet fermetures de
plages à los angeles pas de réouverture
des restaurants à new york ou bien port
du masque obligatoire à miami ainsi
qu'au texas
le gouvernant de cet état a appelé à la
vigilance regarder le qu'ovide 19 n'est
pas en train de disparaître
en réalité ils empirent aujourd'hui plus
que jamais il faut que chacun agisse
jusqu'à ce que des traitements soient
disponibles pour le coc vie de 19
c'est pourquoi j'ai publié aujourd'hui
une obligation de se couvrir le visage
pour tous les comptes et ayant plus de
24 2 co vide
cette norme de sécurité exige que les
texans portent des masques dans les
espaces publics avec certaines
exceptions qui relève du bon sens la
chine de nouveau sous le feu des
critiques américaines washington dénonce
les exercices militaires de pékin en mer
de chine méridionale
les etats unis qui adopte également des
sanctions contre des responsables
chinois qui appliquent les nouvelles
règles sécuritaires et répressives
contre kong
une loi adoptée hier par le congrès
justement pour accroître la pression sur
pékin et à hong kong
une première inculpation a été prononcée
ce matin en vertu de cette nouvelle loi
sur la sécurité et la medjahed
il ya des objections à la poursuite de
cette mesure sans objection le c de la
poursuivre à la procédure le sénat
américain à majorité républicaine a
approuvé à l'unanimité le train de
sanctions contre la répression à hong
kong
républicains et démocrates sont donc
désireux de renforcer la pression sur
pékin qui a promulgué mardi dernier une
loi sur la sécurité nationale dans l'ex
colonie britannique dans l'hémicycle
tous ont souligné ce jeudi l'urgence de
la situation à hong kong un profond
soutien à ce texte de sanctions contre
la chine qui arrive au lendemain de son
approbation par la chambre des
représentants contrôlée par les
démocrates et niasse hier nous avons
adopté la loi hong kong autonomie acte
qui avait déjà été adopté par le sénat
et qui doit contribuer à mettre fin à la
campagne de cruauté de la chine envers
hong kong
vous m'avez entendu le dire encore et
encore si nous ne dénonçons pas les
violations des droits de l'homme en
chine en raison d'intérêts commerciaux
nous perdons toute autorité morale pour
dénoncer les violations des droits de
l'homme partout dans le monde
la loi contre la répression à hong kong
devra encore être promulgué par donald
trump pour entrer en vigueur
pour l'instant la maison blanche n'a pas
indiqué si le président comptait le
faire ou mettre son veto cette union
républicains démocrates montre en tout
cas que les parlementaires américains
pourrait être en mesure doute repasser
un veto présidentiel le cas échéant
cette future loi va bien plus loin que
les sanctions adoptée l'an dernier par
le congrès puis promulgué par le
président américain
objectif de ce nouveau texte visé non
seulement les responsables chinois mais
aussi la police de hong kong
des sanctions qui seront déclenchées
obligatoirement contre ceux qui
s'attaquent aux libertés promise au
peuple
hong kong et autre point crucial avec
cette loi washington pourrait
sanctionner les banques qui placerait
leurs bénéfices au dessus des droits
humains fondamentaux et des mesures
contre la chine qui alimente un peu plus
la colère de pékin nous
exhortons les états unis à bien
comprendre la situation à respecter le
droit international et les normes
fondamentales régissant les relations
internationales
washington doit cesser de s'immiscer
dans les affaires de hong kong de
quelques manières que ce soit ait stoppé
l'examen et la promotion du projet de
loi contre pékin sinon la chine prendra
certainement de fortes mesures en
réponse et toutes les conséquences
seront supportés par la partie
américaine lient les sanctions
américaines sont un nouveau signe de
l'aggravation des tensions entre les
etats-unis et la chine
la loi sur la sécurité nationale
promulguée par le président chinois xi
jinping fait craindre à l'opposition
hong kongaise recul des libertés pour
les états unis comme pour d'autres pays
occidentaux royaume uni en tête
pékin cherche surtout à travers son
texte à museler l'opposition
après les manifestations monstres de
l'an dernier moins de 24 heures après
son entrée en vigueur la police
hongkongaise avait d'ailleurs procédé ce
mercredi à ses premières arrestations
autre signe de tension entre les
etats-unis et la chine washington a
dénoncé la nuit dernière les exercices
militaires de pékin en mer de chine
méridionale
le pentagone a qualifié ces activités
comme des stabilisatrices encore
davantage de la situation dans cette
zone qui est revendiquée par la chine et
par le vietnam et par taïwan
ce dernier pays soutenus par les états
unis voyez ce qu'en dit jean françois di
mailhiot il est président de l'institut
de recherche asia centre le niveau des
sanctions américaines y compris leurs
caves et 7 selon la guerre commerciale
était supérieur au niveau des anciens
clients a lancé noël c'est proportionnel
et c'est normal puisque de toute façon
la chine exporte plus en termes purement
commerciaux que les états unis exportent
vers la chine donc tout est forcément et
je pense qu'il ya une posture qui
apparaît de plus en plus ces temps-ci
qui fait que en même temps que la chine
est assise sur ce qu'elle appelle son
endroit dans tout ce qu'ils
considéraient comme son territoire
on y compris
à paraître sinon comme le gentil en tout
cas comme le moins méchant dans
l'agressivité
donc ces sanctions qui seront annoncées
elles seront probablement moins
effective moins forte et d'un niveau
moins élevé que ce que washington
prêtant à ce stade
appliqué il reste à voir ensuite la
dimension de l'application des soutes
pas a lancé par l'anssi pelosi par le
sénat et le congrès et en turquie
ouverture du procès aujourd'hui par
contumace des assassins de jamal
khashoggi ce journaliste saoudien qui a
été tuée et démembrée dans le consulat
d'arabie saoudite à istanbul
c'était en octobre 2018 retour sur cette
affaire en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
mais
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité sur notre antenne rester
avec nous on se retrouve dans 30 minutes
[Musique]
en pleine crise du coroner viol après
avoir constaté l'incapacité de l'union
européenne à manifester la moindre
solidarité envers des étapes l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet